spoken are you looking at yourself as an
activist never
no the greatest teachers teach without
teaching i don't want to get a
standard no pull pit in and and be like
hey y'all follow me
just just just look at the way i live my
life and judge me based on that
i know that's not how the word it goes
it doesn't go the way we want it to go
yeah
i see you i i'm going to follow him you
can't stop them from falling
it's just that way yeah that's a field
man
you know it's all love okay leader i
never wanted to be no big leader
oh man you're already a leader what do
you want to do
unfortunately no i'm from france what do
you do
but it's been adorned on you by god yeah
so
you know what i mean you think oh i made
a mistake you're muslim man i know you
know
i know you know better you just talking
hollywood stuff but you know
now i'm gonna be honest with you though
that's that's been one of my biggest
fears of
people following me like all my life i
knew i was chosen
i knew i used to do [ __ ] to to kind of
sabotage my path to sabotage my career
same thing i used to i used to sabotage
my own career i would get in my own way
to keep from having to carry out this
great responsibility that god bestowed
upon me
it's called what was it called
survivor's guilt
you ever heard about that you heard that
survivor's guilt no sir
that um you feel guilty that you made in
the mother guys what you didn't make it
they were smarter than you had more
organization than you but you made it
right
and more family than you more everything
mortality more everything than you
but they didn't make it but it was but
it was set for them to make it had
everything to make it that you did but
you made it
right did you have that mike did you did
you feel that
would he talk about it yeah i knew i was
special i used to always think i was jim
brown and jim kelly from three to
hallway and [ __ ]
yeah you know but i was in my mind like
if somebody picked them in the street
i'd be scared and run or something
it was always in my mind and when i had
that first fight when the guy killed my
pigeon
it was over the first time i was like i
had to fight fought everyday i almost
had three four fights a day
as i was i wanted because i just saw
your documentary too on cbs i did a good
job
is that when you is that when you
discovered your ability mike
yeah and so the guys who used to pick on
me taught me how to
you know hit guys knock out and go in
their pockets and get their money
so they the guys used to pick on me
after i started fighting back
they became my friend then they showed
me the ropes how to rob houses how to
pick pockets and that's
chains and all that stuff oh damn like
that y'all became my friend
[Music]